Bonjour à tous
Aujourd'hui on va parler de ce que certains considèrent comme le problème le plus important
et le plus difficile des mathématiques :
l'hypothèse de Riemann
Cette hypothèse a été formulée en 1859
par le mathématicien allemand Bernhard Riemann
et jusqu'ici
personne n'a réussi à la démontrer
même si la plupart des chercheurs pensent qu'elle est très certainement vraie.
Vous avez peut-être qu'en mathématiques il existe un certain nombre de situations de ce type
des conjectures que tous les mathématiciens
considèrent comme vrai
mais que personne n'arrive à démontrer.
Alors pourquoi l'hypothèse de Riemann est-elle si particulière ?
Déjà d'un point de vue bassement matériel, il faut savoir qu'elle fait partie des sept problèmes dit "du millénaire"
pour lesquels l'institut Clay offre un prix d'un million de dollars à qui en trouvera une solution.
Mais ça, les vrais mathématiciens s'en fichent.
Ce qui les fascine avant tout,
c'est que l'hypothèse de Riemann
propose une connexion entre deux champs des mathématiques
qui à première vue n'ont pas grand chose à voir.
D'un côté, les nombres premiers
et de l'autre côté, un domaine qu'on appelle l'analyse complexe.
Et pour bien comprendre ce lien qu'établit l'hypothèse de Riemann
on va commencer par parler du plus simple de ces deux domaines : les nombres premiers.
Commençons par rappeler ce qu'est un nombre premier: il s'agit d'un nombre entier qu'on ne peut pas diviser
à part par 1 et par lui-même, évidemment.
Par convention on exclut le 1 et donc les nombres premiers on en connaît plein : 2 3 5 7 11 13 etc.
Depuis très longtemps les mathématiciens se posent plein de questions sur les nombres premiers :
Quelle quantité il y en a ?
Comment ils se répartissent ?
Où est-ce qu'on en trouve ?
Certaines de ces questions sont résolues depuis bien longtemps, par exemple il y a plus de 2000 ans
Euclide avait déjà démontré qu'il existe une infinité de nombres premiers.
On sait aussi que les nombres premiers se raréfient, on en trouve de moins en moins souvent à mesure qu'ils augmentent.
Par exemple entre 0 et 100 on en trouve 25, donc un quart des nombres sont premiers dans cet intervalle.
Mais entre 1000 et 1100 il n'y en a plus que 16
et entre 1 000 000 et 1 000 100, on en trouve seulement 6
Pour comprendre la manière dont se distribuent les nombres premiers et pour représenter où on en trouve
on peut définir une fonction très simple qu'on appelle la fonction de répartition.
C'est une fonction qui compte simplement la quantité de nombres premiers entre 0 et x
Si on cherche tous les nombres premiers, par exemple entre 0 et 200, et qu'on trace cette fonction
On voit qu'elle a évidemment une forme en escalier, à chaque nombre premier elle augmente de 1.
Ici on peut lire la valeur que je mentionnais tout à l'heure, il y a 25 nombres premiers entre 0 et 100
Et de façon générale
puisque les nombres premiers se raréfient, on va avoir des plateaux de plus en plus longs avec des marches d'escalier de moins en moins souvent.
Pour tracer cette fonction de répartition on n'a malheureusement pas de formule toute faite
on est obligé de chercher tous les nombres premiers dans un certain intervalle.
Puis à partir de la liste, de tracer la fonction.
Et chercher tous les nombres premiers dans un intervalle c'est assez fastidieux parce qu'on est forcé d'une façon ou d'une autre
de traiter tous les nombres afin d'éliminer ceux qui ne sont pas premiers.
Cette fonction de répartition on ne sait donc pas la tracer sans avoir préalablement la liste des nombres premiers.
Mais on en connaît quelques approximations.
La première c'est la fonction x/log(x)
C'est une fonction très simple dont la forme générale suit celle de la fonction de répartition
et qui permet comme ça de connaître en gros la quantité de nombres premiers dans un intervalle donné.
Même si, vous le voyez, elle est toujours un peu en dessous de la réalité.
Mais il existe une autre approximation un peu meilleure que ça,
c'est une fonction qu'on appelle le logarithme intégral, noté Li(x)
Ici elle est tracée entre 0 et 1000, et vous voyez que c'est pas trop mal
on est un peu au dessus de la fonction de répartition cette fois,
mais tracée entre 0 et 100 000 vous voyez que ça colle assez bien - mieux que la fonction précédente.
Alors une des choses qu'a faites Riemann c'est d'abord de proposer une approximation
encore meilleure que celle-ci, qui est une variante fabriquée à partir de la fonction Li(x)
et qu'on note parfois Ri(x), en hommage à Riemann justement.
Si je trace cette fonction Ri(x) vous voyez que là
c'est vraiment une très bonne approximation de la fonction de répartition, elle passe vraiment bien au milieu.
Parfois elle est légèrement au dessus, parfois légèrement en dessous, mais dans l'ensemble c'est vraiment pas mal du tout
Le problème de cette approximation c'est qu'elle suit la tendance générale mais elle n'a pas du tout cette structure en escalier qu'a la fonction de répartition
et par conséquent, elle ne nous dit rien des endroits où se produisent les petits sauts, et où se trouvent précisément les nombres premiers.
On ne peut donc pas utiliser cette approximation pour deviner à l'avance où vont se trouver les nombres premiers.
Un truc qui fait rêver les mathématiciens, ce serait de posséder une expression,
une formule, une fonction de ce genre qui aurait la structure en escalier - de façon à pouvoir prédire précisément la localisation des nombres premiers.
L'idéal serait d'avoir la formule d'une fonction qui fasse un peu comme ça
Et bien c'est ça qu'a réussi à faire Riemann
enfin.. presque, et pour vous faire comprendre comment on va devoir faire un détour par quelque chose qui n'a en apparence rien à voir
les sommes infinies.
En mathématiques on peut faire des additions. On peut additionner deux nombres, trois nombres,
29 nombres.. autant que vous voulez en fait. Mais en plus de ça, il existe des circonstances
particulières dans lesquelles on peut faire la somme d'une infinité de nombres.
Prenons un exemple simple :
considérez la somme 1/2+1/4+1/8+1/16+1/32+1/64 etc. jusqu'à l'infini
C'est une somme qu'on peut calculer progressivement
et si vous le faites, vous allez vous rendre compte qu'on se rapproche de plus en plus de 1
Ça se voit très bien si on en fait une représentation comme des parts de gâteau
On a une somme, avec une infinité de termes, mais dont le résultat est un nombre fini : on dit qu'elle converge.
Ces sommes infinies, les mathématiciens appellent ça des séries.
Alors oui attention - si un matheux ou une matheuse vous propose de venir chez lui
"regarder des séries"
méfiez-vous ça va pas être exactement Netflix & chill
Bref, une somme infinie c'est une série, et parfois -mais pas toujours- la série converge vers une valeur finie.
Les séries on peut en fabriquer plein, par exemple
1 + 1/4 + 1/9 + 1/16 + 1/25 etc.
Vous remarquez le motif : au dénominateur on met le carré des nombres entiers.
Et cette série converge vers 1,6449 et des brouettes
On peut aussi faire la même avec des cubes au lieu des carrés des nombres entiers.
1 + 1 sur 2 au cube + 1 sur 3 au cube + 1 sur 4 au cube etc... et la série converge aussi vers
1,202 et quelques
Et ce principe on peut essayer de le généraliser avec n'importe quelle puissance
même des puissances de nombres qui ne sont pas des entiers
Disons.. 6,3
Et bien on peut écrire
1 + 1 sur 2 puissance 6.3
+ 1 sur 3 puissance 6,3
+ 1 sur 4 puissance 6,3 etc...
Vous voyez peut-être où je veux en venir : ce petit jeu on peut le faire avec n'importe quel nombre x
et donc, de façon générale, on peut considérer la fonction suivante
1 + 1 sur 2 puissance x + 1 sur 3 puissance x + 1 sur 4 puissance x etc
Et on peut montrer que dès que x est strictement plus grand que 1, et bien la série converge et la fonction a un sens.
Alors normalement à ce stade vous vous demandez pourquoi j'ai introduit la fonction f(x) à la définition si alambiquée
et quel rapport ça peut avoir avec les nombres premiers. Et bien la raison c'est une drôle de relation
découverte avant Riemann par le mathématicien suisse Leonhard Euler :
Cette fonction f(x) est exactement égale à cette expression, qui est cette fois un produit infini.
Et si vous la regardez de près, vous remarquez que dans ce produit infini on ne trouve pas un terme pour chaque nombre entier
mais seulement chaque nombre premier.
La formule d'Euler peut vous sembler étrange avec cette histoire de produits infinis
mais elle nous montre qu'il existe une connexion profonde avec les nombres premiers.
Et ce lien, Bernhard Riemann l'a poussé beaucoup plus loin.
Je vous j'ai dit, la fonction f(x) n'est définie que pour des nombres x strictement plus grands que 1.
Ce qu'a fait Riemann, c'est de montrer qu'on peut prolonger la définition de cette fonction
de façon beaucoup plus large
notamment pour les nombres complexes.
Alors petite parenthèse, les nombres complexes ce sont ceux qu'on peut écrire sous la forme
z = x + i * y
où i est le nombre imaginaire, tel que i carré égale -1
Un nombre complexe z, il faut donc deux nombres réels x et y pour le décrire
Le moyen le plus simple de visualiser les nombres complexes
c'est de se dire qu'il se représentent comme des points du plan, de coordonnées x et y. On appelle l'ensemble le plan complexe
là où les nombres réels ne sont qu'une droite.
Et comme je l'ai dis, ce qu'a trouvé Riemann c'est un moyen de prolonger la définition de la fonction
depuis cette portion de droite
jusqu'à l'ensemble du plan des nombres complexes.
Cette opération de prolongement, elle a rien d'évident et je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
Pour les curieux, il y a une vidéo de El Jj et une autre de 3Blue1Brown qui l'expliquent très bien.
Ce qu'il faut retenir, c'est que ce prolongement est en quelque sorte unique
et donc Riemann a trouvé la seule façon de définir cette fonction sur tous les nombres complexes.
Cette fonction prolongée on l'appelle la fonction zêta
(ben oui parce que les lettres grecques ça fait quand même plus chic)
Voilà, vous connaissez maintenant
la fameuse fonction zêta de Riemann
et grâce à la relation
qu'avait découvert Euler avant lui
vous comprenez qu'elle a certainement un vague lien avec les nombres premiers.
Bien, alors revenons maintenant
à notre problème d'origine :
la répartition de ces nombres premiers.
Je vous l'ai déjà, dit la fonction Ri(x) introduite par Riemann
est une très bonne approximation de la fonction de répartition, mais elle n'a pas du tout le comportement en marche d'escalier.
Et ce qu'a découvert Riemann, c'est une fonction qui a cette forme et qui est une simple modification de la fonction Ri(x)
Pour ça, on part de la fonction Ri
et on va lui apporter
des petites déformations, des corrections.
Ce qui est génial c'est que ces corrections s'expriment aussi à partir de la fonction Ri
mais en l'évaluant au point x puissance z
pour tous les points complexes z où la fonction zêta s'annule.
Alors expliquons ça tranquillement pour être bien clair. On peut imaginer que la fonction zêta
s'annule en un certain nombre de points du plan complexe.
Ces points là, on les appelle les Zéros de la fonction zêta.
Supposons qu'on les connaisse, et appelons Z1, Z2, Z3 etc ...
Pour faire les corrections dont je parlais, vous partez de la fonction Ri(x) et vous lui retirez Ri(x puissance z)
pour chacun des Zéros
on fait donc Ri(x) - Ri(x) puissance Z1 - Ri(x) puissance Z2  - Ri(x) puissance Z3, etc...
Chaque Zéro de la fonction zêta fournit une petite correction.
Ce qu'a démontré Riemann, c'est que si on connaît tous les Zéros de la fonction zêta,
alors en faisant toutes les corrections
on tombe exactement sur la fonction de répartition des nombres premiers, avec sa structure en escalier.
Alors ok très bien, mais maintenant il va falloir les trouver ces Zéros - et je vous rappelle qu'on doit ler chercher
parmi les nombres complexes, donc dans le plan complexe.
Alors pour ça, sur ce dessin, j'ai représenté en niveaux de gris ce qu'on appelle le module de la fonction zêta
plus cette valeur est faible plus le gris est clair, et les Zéros correspondent donc aux points blancs de cette image.
On peut observer deux choses :
Tout d'abord on a des Zéros en -2, -4, -6, -8 etc...
en fait pour tous les nombres pairs négatifs, la fonction zêta s'annule.
On sait le démontrer, et c'est ce que les mathématiciens appelle les zéros triviaux de la fonction.
Mais vous voyez qu'on a d'autres Zéros ici, et ils semblent tous alignés sur cette droite verticale
qui est celle qui correspond aux nombres complexes de partie réelle 1/2
On appelle cette droite : la droite critique.
Si on trace spécifiquement la fonction zêta
le long de cette droite critique,
en oubliant tout le reste du plan,
voici ce qu'on observe. Vous voyez qu'on trouve plein de zéros, alors c'est bien
mais d'une part ils n'ont rien de remarquables
ce ne sont pas des nombres entiers ou demi entiers ou autre chose de ce genre, ils ont l'air un peu aléatoires, et en plus
on ne distingue pas de régularité particulière dans leur répartition. Parfois on a beaucoup d'espace entre deux, parfois ils s'enchaînent presque immédiatement.
Et la question que s'est posée Riemann c'est,
à part -2, -4, -6 etc ..
Est ce que tous les zéros de la fonction zêta sont sur cette droite critique, ou bien est-ce qu'il en existerait d'autres ailleurs ?
Et c'est important, puisque la connaissance de ces zéros
permet de faire toutes les corrections dont on a besoin pour retrouver la fonction de répartition des nombres premiers.
Et bien c'est ça qu'on appelle
l'hypothèse de Riemann
L'affirmation selon laquelle
tous les zéros (non triviaux)
se trouvent sur la droite critique.
Alors on a de très bonnes raisons de penser que c'est vrai puisque pour l'instant on en a trouvé plus de dix mille milliards sur cette droite
et jamais aucun en dehors. Mais vous savez qu'en maths, ça ne garantit pas que ce soit vrai tout le temps.
Pour vous illustrer l'intérêt de cette hypothèse, regardez ce qu'elle permet de faire :
Ici, j'ai la fonction de répartition des nombres premiers en bleu,
avec sa structure en escalier, et la fonction Ri en rouge.
Et maintenant, je vais au fur et à mesure
ajouter des corrections
en prenant successivement les zéros
qu'on trouve sur la droite critique.
Et bien vous voyez que ça ajoute des petites corrections en oscillations
qui, quand on en a ajouté suffisamment, finissent par très bien suivre les escaliers de la fonction de répartition
et nous disent donc exactement où trouver les nombres premiers.
On a même l'impression qu'au bout d'un moment, on n'a même plus besoin d'ajouter des corrections supplémentaires
Alors malheureusement plus on veut aller loin dans le tracé de la courbe plus il va falloir ajouter de corrections
et donc plus il sera important d'être certain qu'on n'a pas loupé des zéros de la fonction zêta.
Si l'hypothèse de Riemann est vraie
on peut se contenter de les chercher sur la droite critique,
mais dans le cas contraire, on est cuit : on risque d'en louper.
En résumé la fonction zêta contient donc en elle la clé de la répartition des nombres premiers.
Alors en pratique utiliser les zéros de la fonction zêta n'est peut-être pas le moyen le plus simple de trouver des nombres premiers
mais l'intérêt théorique de l'hypothèse de Riemann réside surtout dans le pont qu'elle établit entre ces deux domaines si éloignés
l'arithmétique et l'analyse complexe
Aujourd'hui on l'a dit, la plupart des mathématiciens considèrent que l'hypothèse de Riemann est vraie, et qu'il doit être possible d'en trouver une démonstration.
Mais ça semble pour le moins.. velu, comme problème
D'ailleurs il y a un siècle le mathématicien
David Hilbert disait déjà que s'il se réveillait d'un sommeil de 1000 ans
la première question qu'ils poseraient serait est-ce que l'hypothèse de Riemann a été démontrée.
Alors évidemment, certains mathématiciens essayent de la trouver cette démonstration.
Mais d'autres font ce qu'on fait parfois en mathématiques : ils partent du principe que l'hypothèse est vraie, et regardent ce qu'on peut démontrer avec.
Je vous donne un exemple un peu fou : vous vous souvenez de mes fonctions d'approximation, au début ?
Il y avait la fonction x/log(x), qui semble toujours en dessous de la fonction de répartition, et puis la fonction Li(x)
qui elle semblait plus proche, mais toujours au dessus.
Et bien, on sait depuis environ un siècle que non, elle n'est pas toujours au dessus : il y a un moment où elle passe en dessous
puis après elle revient au dessus et repasse en dessous etc...
Et en fait, on peut démontrer que les deux courbes se croisent une infinité de fois. Le problème c'est qu'on n'a jamais pu l'observer
on a regardé jusqu'à des milliards de milliards, pas de croisement.
On peut donc légitimement se demander à partir de quel moment va se produire le premier croisement.
Le mathématicien Stanley Skewes a pu démontrer qu'il devait forcément se produire avant 10 puissance 10 puissance 10 puissance 964
Alors sachant qu'il y a 10 puissance 80 atomes dans l'univers visible, c'est un nombre qu'on pourrait même pas écrire si on voulait, mais bon
Et bien en supposant que l'hypothèse de Riemann soit vraie,
Skewes a pu améliorer le résultat en montrant que l'inversion devait se produire en fait avant 10 puissance 10 puissance 10 puissance 34.
Un nombre incroyablement plus petit que le précédent
mais qu'on peut toujours pas écrit non plus.
Et mieux, en faisant des approximations
avec les zéros de la fonction zêta qu'on connaît, et en supposant qu'il n'y en a pas ailleurs,
on a pu resserrer le résultat, et on pense maintenant que la première inversion devrait se produire autour de 10 puissance 316
... ça fait loin quand même.
Une chose que j'ai mentionné au début de la vidéo, et qui n'a peut-être pas échappé à certains, c'est que
l'hypothèse de Riemann fait partie des sept problèmes du millénaire à 1 million de dollars.
Mais bon, vu le calibre de l'énigme on peut considérer que tenter de démontrer l'hypothèse de Riemann est
probablement la manière la plus inefficace et la plus incertaine qui soit d'essayer de gagner un million de dollars.
À moins que...
.. à moins qu'elle soit fausse !
Dans ce cas c'est simple : trouver 1 point d'annulation,
un seul qui ne soit pas sur la droite critique et vous êtes bon,  à vous le magot.
Alors une piste si c'est ça votre stratégie,
On sait montrer que les zéros non triviaux ne peuvent exister que dans la bande entre 0 et 1 de partie réelle
C'est ce qu'on appelle la bande critique. Et en plus de ça, l'immense majorité des zéros se trouve tout près de la droite critique
Donc voilà vous savez où chercher si vous voulez trouver un contre-exemple à l'hypothèse de Riemann
Mais.. je sais pas, je ne parierais pas trop dessus quand même. Alors sachez tout de même que fin
2018, le mathématicien Michael Atiyah a proposé une démonstration de l'hypothèse de Riemann
qui malheureusement ne semble pas du tout convaincre la communauté.
Et pour en savoir plus, je vous renvoie à cette vidéo de Professeur Culture Précieuse
Voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui. Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo, comme toujours le blog pour les compléments, facebook et twitter pour l'actu de la chaîne,
Abonnez-vous la cloche tout ça, et on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo. A bientôt.